these are plants that support beneficial  insects but also  away from the this is an example of a  Fantana branch that has a lot of white  flannel lower leaves and it's clean of  Wi-Fi from here on up because the  natural enemies have killed all the  paths in the beginning of the season and  then the plant has produced natural  enemies for the rest of the season to  control the path we've got four Guardian  plants in this this black pearl little  trip and it will produce aureus  marigolds is a very very important  thrips control agent it pulls thrips  away from many many crops azorius  montana pulls Wi-Fi and produce this  white flight parasite this barley  produces a fits that produce white  flight or a food parasite fuchsia yeah  this fuchsia it's a single fuchsia  beautiful little plant big plan  eventually pulls whitefly and produce a  white pie parasite